quand même la mention
j'adore
ne baisse jamais les bras mais vous
pouvez l'oublier jusqu'à la menacer 2,29
à la france ne laissera pas ce que pour
les femmes on a envie d'apparaître pour
féminin pour qualifier ce qu'on est
content des lecteurs on est une battante
j'espère que beaucoup parmi vous qui
seront demain 3 pour dépasser tout et
défis
avant de commencer souple et moi cette
histoire
j'étais un de 3 ans chez des amis et moi
une victoire ce que veut dire que ça me
fait me rends compte uc est bien
placé je vais dire dix mois que
j'ai dit mais pour voir un peu de rêve
aux bonnes elle va dîner jamais personne
ne m'a dit qu'il fallait avoir un m
et ce qui vient avant ça me paraît peu
mixte histoire m'a donné quelques vous
allez entrer chez mais là mais personne
ne vient la jeune fille petit rat a dit
le second à champier samedi que cela
pouvait progressive les invités elle a
passé le permis de conduire à la
formation en esthétique et coiffure
mêmes malheurs de dvd préparer sans
armes de dieu il a près de faire des
économies pour arriver à battre ensemble
peuvent le broker est simplement rêver a
changé sa vie et d'un fermier qui va se
passer à nant be seen on est les
personnes vous voyez à faire la même
chose que ce qu'elle faisait qui n'était
pas drôle mais que qu'il ne lui
donnerait pas de perspectives
alors voilà j'ai choisi d'appeler un
bond à 17 la motion ils sont de fins
politiques parce que bien sûr quand
j'entends parler de succès qui se
construisent à partir les échecs gilles
soie vert amande et j'ai choisi pour la
montée avec quelques photos alors après
tout c'est quand j'avais 7 ans c'est pas
vous faire des amis bien évidement que
souffle un bon c'est parce que je crois
que c'est l'un des espoirs à seulement
que jamais leur science de l'enfance
devant j'ai perdu mon père est
pénalisé leurs cinq enfants cette femme
de 32 ans manet et tout le monde a dit
cette femme issue parce que perdre plus
d'argent
elle a eu le sens du défi et c'est comme
objectif de faire inviter ses sept
enfants et elle va fêter cette petit peu
mais devant ses supérieurs apprennent ce
que quelqu'un que j'aime bien pensé qui
existaient toutes les femmes qui sont la
négation de soi dans nos manuels de
coaching matériel dans la gaieté
centimes à leur coaching mains des
rebelles enfin les qualités qu'ils font
pour donner confiance en soi des enfants
et comme on appelait apparaît comme mama
par les élèves et city lui le ps si moi
il m'appelle inscrit et quand on pense
qu'un solide allié
j'ai passé mon bac à 18 ans un roman bh
vous et quel est le but des films parce
qu'on avait pas d'argent et c'était donc
été très mauvaise c'était un début pour
nous d'arriver quand même place au
combiné quand j'ai passé mon bac je peux
lui faire un médecin à rabat mais bien
des conditions qui ont fait le
quelqu'un d'arabie qui avait promis de
s'occuper de moi ça veut dire payer moi
je ne voulais pas
aller en france on va
profiter aux jeux d'argent j'ai obtenu
ma bourse à l'époque c'était plus facile
que maintenant il fallait faire par
massy pour la bonne bouche donc j'ai
choisi de faire massivement pour aller
en france
j'ai travaillé pendant les trois mois
d'été comme standardiste à 500 grammes
avoir à l'époque et avec les 500 grammes
par mois sur les trois mois j'ai pu
partager avec ma mère connaît une partie
vous laisse écouter les autres et une
partie pourquoi agents français donc
c'est parce que je suis en france ne
s'était pas donné comme ça
et par la suite
j'ai lu donc à l'ouvragé pour sauver ce
qu est l injustice sociale
les problèmes et où le maroc est un pays
pauvre j'ai pu lui apporter beaucoup
plus riche plus
en plus instruits que les choses
allaient mieux c'était propre s'était
développé ses vaches je suis dit dan mon
dieu pourquoi le marin n'est pas comme
la france tout comme la maman tu n'es
pas payé d'avancés les parties est
produit et je me disais
rafa a été plus sous-développées encore
que le marrant je dis merci le marin si
la france est devenue ce qu'elle est
c'est parce qu'il ya des gens qui ont
fait ce qu'il fallait qu'ils ont
bataillé communiqué qu'ils ont fait est
ce qu'il avait à faire pour changer des
choses et je me suis dit pourquoi
barbara
on pourrait également faire à mon jeu si
on s'engage et j'avais pris l'engagement
sur moi-même que je vais m'en donnez
jamais militantisme que toute ma vie je
serai engagé pour que le maroc soit lieu
de ce qu'il est maintenant qu'ils
puissent faire de belles photos on peut
ainsi se branchait adhéré au ps je sais
pas si ça vous dit quelque chose c'est
vous dire
bon le psc1 du successeur du parti
communiste marocain qui était un cadeau
et
vous avez reconstituer une partie des
marocains est interdite le plr et ps a
ressenti quelques années que c'est le ps
qui a un successeur du ps
ça c'est juste quelques gp les quelques
mois en ciel que j'allais vous avez
scanner donc ils s'embarquent écart type
ubs de plusieurs les années 2000
ça fait quand même bien
quand je suis rentré de france la
première événements et qui est devant
les supermarchés rewe pour l'achèvement
de l'intégration
c'était franchement c'était en
mais je suis quand même mais force est
de
tous les premières sélections du sud
c'était une élection municipale
de
il n'y avait pas de femmes
y avaient élu municipal n'est pas
quitter eelv henri extrêmement rare en
politique mais c'est un domaine qui
m'attire énormément et donc je me suis
présenté aux élections ici je vous aime
il craquer
mais
bon c'était même à tort que vous avez
vous fait un mouvement du 20 février ça
veut dire
une gestion démocratique de la vie pour
une réappropriation de la population et
ses richesses cook vous l'avez vous fera
corruption vous verrez c'est maintenant
qu'il est extrêmement proche de ce qu'il
avait dit ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui les
deuxièmes élections auxquelles je te
suivrai en ville c'est d'ailleurs en
1977 et là c'est original parce que
j'étais la seule candidate rats a
tellement bien c'est à dire dans tout le
maroc avec un but vain
qui des candidats quatre hommes engagés
fait la seule et je crois qu'à ce moment
là quand je venais me présenter devant
les électeurs il me regardait tous mes
enfants me regarder comme ça vous êtes
en courant sont bien loin des fastes une
vague cet effet ce nouveau spectacle
n'est qu'une femme puisse se présenter
aux élections mais il avait un
incroyable je n'ai pas été nul à
376 me manquer
en 77 jeux face à une équipe est
également engagé en politique mais
n'avait pas vous dire que mon père le
registre phone c'est difficile c'est pas
facile de territoire est immense il
faudra compter c'est très difficile
quand j'étais ça fait rien pour voir
important et il se présentait hélas
chaque fois qu'on vous dise et deux
femmes a réussi 10 même réussi on me
disait tu vas pas du tout mais je n'ai
pas été élu mais j'ai l'appel d'autres
objectifs premièrement de montrer la vie
de participer sélection des mondes de
donner l'exemple aux petites filles
parce que des petites filles sous la
main et elle s était fier mada du poids
parce que j'étais quelqu'un j'étais
quelqu'un qui écoute et sa garantie aux
élections et se projeter se voit quand
je leur donne un exemple et d'autres
objectifs que je voulais la faire dévier
un vaccin est aussi à croquer le
chantier parce que pour une femme ce
n'est pas habituel de semaine par les
deux bouts il est un peu les jambes pas
même des gens pas parce qu'une conquête
de la liberté aussi enfin au lieu de
façon à
pouvoir
parler aux gens et de
la situation de la
sélection
j'ai rencontré mon compagnon de vie si
je
vous disais si vous voulez voir à la
voix
tamara et moi j'ai fait une formation
enfants soldats j'avais vraiment du mal
à france 2
j'étais choquée parce que c'est très
difficile pour moi d'affronter la
population darretche en comparant avec
un amateur et pour eux
on sait que l'on quitte pas matière à la
lame de fond p c'était vraiment réussi
pour moi à la 3e fois
face à mon
sens il
faut vous dire quel était son les
combats j'ai participé la cité une photo
une souris parce qu'il ya des gens que
vous connaissez vêtements mais vous
connaissez dernière main de
son dirigeant charismatique legrand
fondateur parti communiste
il ya des gens ici qu aimer
mode et ses actifs et qui était encore
tout jeu vidéo est là vous reconnaissez
les crédits de passionnés qui est ici
vous connaissez peut-être je ne dirai
quand c'est bien repoussé par semaine
tout ça c'est uniquement vidéo nous
avons bien aux élections législatives de
mars en attaque et pour tout dire une
semi son événement qui me manque mais
les élections municipales qui ont le
mieux j'ai cependant 84 22 pouces mais
j'ai pas trouvé de
mais je ne vais pas assommer
législatives de juin contre la grèce
d'une des candidates comme elle
ensuite toujours des élections de 93 et
tu viens tu es septième élection qui
sont en 97 alors que sexy mais reculé de
1976 à 1996
tellement bien j'ai fait vraiment de
campagne électorale avant les
municipales mais j'étais parmi les 400
de femmes
et ça passe
1600 les 4 6 ans
mais il était vraiment très limités et
donc voici vraiment évidemment pas
réussi à être muni cipal
ensuite les élections législatives
indice est pas content je n'ai pas eu
encore
étudiante assé
99c des élections de la chambre qui
concède il c'était la première fois
qu'on est écrit la chanteuse et des
courses élections indirectes j'ai bien
au quotidien fait j'étais en pneus
lisses et même mes propres gens de ma
liste n'ont pas voté pour moi parce que
c'est souvent ce sont les hommes qui
sont que sainté real boutreux ils sont
également avec d'autres c'est plus pour
échanger 17-10 ferrat s'était pas eu de
sens
pour eux les cdg parfois parce que l'un
des réseaux de soutien jeunesse ou font
sur la base d'intérêts même si elle
avait changé donc je n'ai pas en ce
moment je les bactéries but mais à ce
niveau là je n'ai même pas réussi à
l'aller nous voit les grands électeurs
qu'il est supposé la voter pour moi que
vous allez tous l accord avec bien
d'autres français en échange d'un
intérêt du sco n'est pas toujours mais
qu'ils sont cons fait toucher des mois
il encore
bien pour la deuxième fois
la cimade et ses pouvoirs
les élections législatives
c'était en 2002 c'était la première fois
parce que je pense parallèlement je ne
me suis pas contenté d'être militante au
parti j'étais en avise le deuxième 500
go de ram et notamment l'association
démocratique des femmes du maroc et on
s'était battu pour créer des
associations qui luttent pour la
participation politique n'est pas et
c'est une première que je considère
comme prioritaire par rapport aux autres
problèmes que vivent les femmes comme de
gens pensent de la cubana est elle une
contrainte de lens a la garde
j'estime que 50 des femmes sont en
position prise de décision cemac et
peuvent clairement est le pays contre la
pauvreté des farc comme écrire les
politiques publiques en faveur des
femmes en particulier sachant bénévoles
ne sont pas seulement la moitié de la
société de bernie pouvez également nous
sommes des enfants les personnes âgées
les personnes handicapées toutes les
catégories vulnérables
c'est vrai qu'ils sont les mères de
famille c'est un jet lag et du quotidien
de nos familles je veux donner
l'apparence est extrêmement important
voilà ils ont changé nos conditions donc
tout à l'heure
et ben moi je ne suis pas gêné de dire
que maintenant je me sens je veux le
dire mais jusqu'au bout je me sens
assoiffés de pouvoir agir voire faire
pouvoir changer la réalité du pouvoir
fermi pour les étudier et rencontrer
réalité concrète de la population n'a
pas à rechercher de marché cheuvreux
quand ce n'est pas nous pouvons nous
empêcher vous ne savez jamais jamais une
fois l'objectif qu'elles ont montré ce
n'est pas nous qui domine et des autres
ils sont venus
on se sentirait les habitants se sentent
très fort dans ce sens me plaisait
mouvement ni prévoir mais j'aime sentir
j'ai la possibilité de soutenir par
exemple les associations qui travaillent
pour compléter l'action publique en
raison des enfants de la rue des enfants
handicapés ce que deux des mères des
victimes de violence qui s'occupe de
rembourser
enfin il est utile ce problème de
l'association et quand j'étais en
responsabilité j ai tout fait soutenir
cette association et prenait
généralement à réaliser deux objectifs
et je coupe mes gardes se trompait pas à
rechercher au contraire rebeller c'est
là qu'on voit uniquement les gens qui
ont des idées
pour promouvoir pouvoir des gens qui
veulent changer la manière donc la
soutenir et vous quelques images de la
campagne électorale lors de l'année ce
taux national
est simplement je me aussi que pour les
femmes à la vie politique est un
véritable saut d'obstacles parce que
la vie politique si tu me dis
un mot qui fait que les hommes et par
des hommes et les femmes sont toujours
considérés comme des intrus dans le
domaine politique elles bien revanche
elles sont différemment elles ont des
soucis différents vins pas de choses qui
sont différentes et il en joue
une politique qui est
qui n'est pas toujours comblé sur les
mêmes recherches de soins des actions de
consignes fait une belle action
pragmatique
enfin dans les actions sociales et donc
prenez pas vraiment ce n'est pas ça n'a
jamais été très facile d'arriver en
vaut-il pas tous vous coller des hubs
lie l'homme et
voir en tant que 50 des images de
différentes rechange et des centaines de
photos comme ça que c'est juste une idée
et la sibutramine est au parlement donc
c'était la première fois qu'ils avaient
35 femmes au parlement et au début quand
les fans sont arrivés au prix de 3 et
paris nantes et qui est gay des défunts
étaient vides et une femme qui montait
la tribu que tout le monde se taisait
parce qu'on se demandait ce qu'elle va
savoir par dsk va tomber dans l'épaule
est-ce qu'elle va à trois parties
c'est la grande découverte disons des
paroles de femmes et je suis vraiment
heureux d'avoir vécu ces moments
historiques pour les femmes à ce moment
dans la promotion des droits des femmes
il semblait vraiment être un objectif
très difficile
on venait tous les efforts qu'on ne fait
pas de souci
d'égalité des droits
alors ça c'est le vote du code de la
famille en janvier 2004 nous encontre de
la famille à une minute les associations
trois des femmes qui se sont battues des
situations à lui la volonté politique de
3,6 quitte un groupe
qui manque est bien présente agi pour
l'égalité des droits entre nous à bêler
pas c'est grâce à ce sont là sous
courage politique kane il suffit de
savoir si ce que nous avons et
finalement changer la situation
ainsi créée et elle a pourtant je vous
n'hésite pas parce que vous êtes fatigué
aujourd'hui je pense que nous avons
franchi des pas des clients donc du
chemin à parcourir pour atteindre
l'égalité hommes-femmes ça c'est un
escalier que je voulais à lyon ceux qui
connaissent j'ai trouvé que ça ça ça
vous lisez vraiment prévient partout qui
est ce ne n'est pas ensuite à nous rien
de sélections 2 buts 3 je me suis en
manque a tenté sans succès aux élections
passent quelques changements parce qu'il
est un changement du quan le scrutin
électoral on est précisément tous cru
mais comment donner une petite
circonscription
vous devriez habitants elle assuré
une liste malgré d'immenses dans le gain
toute la ville au détour des pages
difficiles si on n'était pas lié par une
structure que très forte et donc
je ne suis pas plus en plus je me suis
retiré de la liste justement parce que
bon c'est difficile il faut le dire mais
j'ai pu être montés chez nous partons
tgv la première femme nommée celle que
vous parlez encore 2003 des faits que
trop maxime vous étiez aussi les foudres
des gens que vous déranger donc ce qui
fait que vous allez m'aider à me ya une
humanité elle sera distinct cela en
troisième position arrive devant un
geste inusité
que je ne voulais pas en seconde où je
me suis retiré d'ici à trois ans c'est
sûr que
j'en ai plus
ça m'a pas empêché de continuer à
militer dans le parti et à faire un coup
électoral et dessus qui s'étaient
présentés et donc en 2007 est devenue la
nomination en tant que ministre comme un
social de la famille et de la solidarité
parmi les sept femmes et d'enfants
c'était un coup des filles parce que
j'avais des missions concernent la
charge c'était de prendre en charge
après une absence de la population
puisque j'ai pu exister en charge et la
promotion d'une toile f1 trois des
enfants il ne sagit dune a souvent dit
inquiet des milices exclu quand je fais
quelque 80% de la population qui est
dans cette situation
autrement dit il faut le dire avec
humour y a que des hommes riches jeunes
et en bonne santé qui ne rentrait pas
dans le cadre de mobilis les aime tous
les autres n'étaient pas mauvais et pour
faire c'est une slovaque qu'est ce que
j'avais comme chez nous
0 30 cent du budget de l'état dont les
oblige de chercher des formules devant
magic je dirais papier formule magique
justement si le partenariat stratégique
ici c'est d'appliquer la société civile
et d'utiliser les moyens publics pour
renforcer la justice et aussi pour
protection des actions de vielles comme
maxime n'est pas compose de
responsabilité une décision alors sa
sélection de 2020 j'ai mis 9 en 20
occasions de l'enea fouette mines et
minéraux gouvernement tout à l'assumer
l'élection est
fabula la voir dans ces élections là on
est passé de 125
familles aux élections à plus de 38
cents
pour montrer que malgré le fait qu'une
femme se présente en trois ans à chaque
fois aux élections le nombre de femmes
élues ni jean castet extrêmement bas et
ce n'est qu'en 2009 quand il ya eu ce
qu'on appelle des factions arrêt mathy
ou discrimination positive de la plus
assurée direction
en étant ministre est le nom d'un songe
le jeu suit sa longue balle à l'image ça
c'est le la liga c'est la ligue arabe
sachant que la région arabe c'est la
région où les femmes il ya deux ou trois
pour les femmes j'ai eu l'honneur de
préciser
marc hé
oui ça
m'a fait très souvent
j'ai dit moi je craque complètement
soufflé jeudi une fois beaucoup elle va
bien
je ne commence pas par quel bout
commencer a présidé la réunion
ce n'est pas rien de précis
une étude
fera
ses valises entre les mains était sans
motivation
de l'importance de la participation des
jeunes c'est très important pour la
vérification politique important c'est
également
là dessus en disant le déchet aussi bien
que le succès continu à la résulte est
que des faux et de série finissent
toujours par être payant n'a rien changé
photo là c'est un prix que j'ai eues en
italie et prix dans la catégorie
politique pour récompenser les efforts
politiques